[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien je suis ravie de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
émission nous sommes le mercredi 29 mars
voici le programme de ce soir le
palmarès des lycées français est sorti
aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines le
meilleur établissement selon le
classement de nos confrères du Parisien
et celui de Sonia Delaunay à Villepreux
pour établir son classement les médias
se base sur des données fournies par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale comme
le taux de réussite au bac ou le
pourcentage des mentions ont fait le
point dans quelques instants un mot
d'économie et d'emploi aussi ce soir
dans votre 7 8 le groupe ADF spécialiste
dans les services d'ingénierie et de
maintenance industrielle renforce sa
présence à Manille les hameaux déjà
présent dans la commune ils viennent
d'inaugurer un site plus grand
l'objectif booster leur croissance et
pour accompagner cette croissance
l'entreprise prévoit le recrutement de
50 postes nous en parlerons avec Laurent
du fourneau le directeur des opérations
du groupe ADF pour la région
Île-de-France et enfin comme mercredi
nous parlerons également de cinéma dans
votre recette 8 quels sont les films à
ne pas manquer cette semaine nous ferons
le point avec notre journaliste Céline
Charles au programme également le coup
de cœur d'un professionnel du septième
art pour nous replonger dans nos
classiques et avec moi en plateau ce
soir Pascal Renaud bonsoir alors vous
êtes la mère adjoint délégué à
l'événementiel et à la vie associative
pour la commune de Fontenay-le-Fleury
samedi prochain vous organisez une
après-midi olympique sur le plateau
Descartes au programme de nombreuses
animations des découvertes sportives
mais aussi de nombreux athlètes quels
sont quels sont les animations prévues
et qu'elles seront les athlètes de haut
niveau présent alors serait une journée
comme on l'a jamais faite à
Fontenay-le-Fleury une journée ou sur un
même site un même lieu on va pouvoir
faire santé culture développement
durable pratiquer un sport et surtout
rencontrer des athlètes comme vous le
dites donc on a la chance d'avoir des
athlètes comme Guy mormain qui est
guilher sport ancien athlète de haut
niveau qui a été demi fin existe du 200
mètres au championnat du monde
handisport Hassen qui a tout à l'heure
il arrive qui a été médaille d'or du 100
mètres 200 m et 400 mètres avec Assia el
hanouni aux Jeux paralympiques d'Athènes
2004 on aura yvanji qui est un joueur de
Cécifoot qui a été meilleur au
championnat d'Europe en 2022 huitième
aux Jeux paralympiques de Tokyo on aura
Christopher mi-sang pour la boxe il a
été champion de France et champion de
l'Île-de-France des 69 kg on aura une
judokate Marie-Claire resto qui a été
médaillée d'or au Championnat du Monde
1995 et 1997 et qui a vraiment propulsé
judo français
elle avait mes décroché lors olympique
Atlanta de beau palmarès oui et puis on
a Florian grimbaud qui est un coureur
cycliste sur piste spécialiste de
vitesse et en 2021 il était vice
champion du monde et mais les bronze aux
Jeux olympiques en vitesse par équipe à
Tokyo donc voilà donc on aura l'occasion
d'en parler un peu plus en détail tout à
l'heure en en tout cas c'est c'est un
beau palmarès que vous nous présentez là
avec nous également sur ce plateau
Laurent Dufourneau bonsoir alors je le
disais vous êtes le directeur des
opérations
Île-de-France pour le groupe ADF
spécialisé en ingénierie et en
maintenance industrielle vous venez
d'inaugurer un nouveau site à Manille
Lamot un site plus grand vous étiez déjà
présent dans dans la commune c'est un
secteur portant dans dans votre secteur
dans le secteur de la France
nos principaux clients sont dans la
région que ce soit s'affront à l'Est
Renault et surtout l'accessibilité avec
le duplex qui permet d'accéder
rapidement à l'ensemble de la région
parisienne nous pour nous ça apportons
donc on en parlerait également plus en
détail tout à l'heure avec nous
également un plateau de journalistes de
la rédaction de de TV 78 c'est ninja et
Régine rage bonsoir bonsoir alors Céline
vous allez nous présenter les sorties
ciné de cette semaine quels sont les
films à ne pas manquer alors je vais
vous présenter le nouveau film de DC
Comics un film dramatique français sur
le thème de la justice restaurative et
un film d'animation ukrainien donc on
aura adoré la justice restaurative
Régine Raleigh vous allez nous présenter
les informations du jour mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel sera dégagé sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines avec des
températures assez douces 11 degrés à
Rambouillet 12 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles et 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
temps se dégrade un peu avec des averses
à prévoir côté température le
thermomètre montera à 16 degrés en
moyenne sur le département et demain
nous fêterons la saint à m'aider le
point maintenant sur les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Régine rallès on
en parlait en début d'émission vous
commencez ces informations du jour avec
le palmarès des lycées qui a été publié
ce matin et 8 Mathilde comme chaque
année plusieurs médias établissent leur
palmarès des lycées et parmi les
principaux on compte notamment Le
Parisien le monde Le Figaro L'Express ou
encore l'étudiant et ce soir on va
s'attarder sur le classement de nos
confrères du Parisien Yvelines et sur le
podium en première place le lycée il y a
Delaunay à Villepreux suivi du lycée
international à Saint-Germain-en-Laye du
lycée militaire de Saint-Cyr-l'École en
3ème place et alors comment sont établis
ces palmarès ces classements alors les
médias se basent sur des indicateurs qui
sont publiés par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale chaque année et en
l'occurrence pour le Parisien cette
année les principaux critères sur
lesquels ils se sont basés sont par
exemple le nombre de spécialités
proposées par l'établissement ou encore
la diversité sociale des élèves ou
encore la capacité du lycée à les faire
progresser et c'est justement ce qui a
placé en tête en tête du classement le
lycée Sonia Delaunay à Villepreux mais
au final chaque média sa méthodologie
d'où le fait que certains proviseurs
remettent en question la légitimité de
ces palmarès alors dans l'actualité dans
l'actualité également aujourd'hui la SPA
qui recherche des bénévoles régimes et
villa spa recherche des délégués
enquêteurs bénévoles dans les Yvelines
mais alors qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement et bien leur mission c'est de
déceler les mauvais les mauvais
traitements infligés aux animaux et agir
en conséquence alors pour postuler la
procédure de recrutement est assez
rigoureuse il y a deux entretiens un
dossier de candidature à compléter des
formations à suivre une période d'essai
de six mois renouvelable une fois et un
engagement à long terme et si vous
souhaitez vous renseigner davantage vous
pouvez aller sur le site de la spa.fr et
direction maintenance
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse à l'occasion
des Journées Européennes des Métiers
d'Art donc on le rappelle c'est en ce
moment la fondation de Coubertin ouvre
ses ateliers de maîtrise au grand public
les ateliers Saint-Jacques et la
fonderie de Coubertin proposeront des
parcours de visite pour faire découvrir
et partager leur savoir-faire et bien
merci beaucoup Régine ralech et si vous
aussi comme d'habitude vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
[Musique]
on en parlait il y a quelques instants
le groupe ADF vient de s'installer dans
les Yvelines à Manille et amo enfin
vient de s'implanter réellement dans les
Yvelines vu que vous étiez déjà à
Manille les hameaux Laurent Dufourneau
je rappelle vous êtes le directeur des
opérations pour la région
Île-de-France alors ADF en quelques mots
c'est une entreprise spécialisée en
ingénierie et en maintenance
industrielle et vous intervenez dans de
nombreux domaines de très nombreux
domaines aéronautiques spatial énergie
militaire et j'en passe voilà le groupe
fait énormément d'activités alors je
vais simplement les résumer sinon ça
risque d'être long on fait la
l'ingénierie c'est-à-dire qu'on
développe avec nos clients de du début
de leurs besoins jusqu'à la réalisation
l'étude la partie métrologie puisque on
a un la bonne mesure qui fait 140 m²
avec une innovation qui arrivait fin de
l'année dernière une machine qui est
unique en France qui permet de mesurer
sur des diamètres de 2 mètres dans le
micro donc voyez très précis avec une
tête rotative et et on va continuer le
processus avec notre client sur
l'installation et toute la partie
maintenant c'est industrielle mais vous
êtes le seul en Europe à posséder cette
tête rotative
de cette tête rotative avec la
superficie du marbre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est une
tête rotative et une question ça
spécificité la spécificité c'est que
c'est une tête qui va mesurer
directement grâce à une CAO l'ensemble
des points d'une pièce ou d'un outillage
de façon précis pour voir si elle est
conforme ou pas conforme donc grâce à
cette tête rotative on va aller chercher
des points très loin dans la pièce qu'on
pouvait pas faire avant donc c'est ça
qui est un peu la nouveauté il nous
fallait un artifice qu'on appelait un
plateau tournant qu'ils aient tourné la
pièce là c'est la tête qui tourne
elle-même voilà un peu la nouveauté
alors vous êtes présent depuis 20 ans en
Île-de-France et vous avez décidé de
vous installer dans les Yvelines à
Magny-les-Hameaux pourquoi Manille et un
mou alors pourquoi parce que nos comme
je disais en introduction nos principaux
clients sont safran sont à l'Est son
Renault qui sont quand même très
implanté sur cinq sur 50 ans Yvelines et
on a aussi nos clients type d'assaut ou
chaîne Nanterre qui sont accessibles
avec le duplex en une demi-heure vous
êtes rapidement directement chez ses
clients là donc voilà pourquoi et donc
vous passez d'un site de 800 m² à 1600
mètres carrés pourquoi pourquoi plus
grand vous aviez besoin de plus d'espace
pourquoi parce qu'on est passé d'un
atelier de 300 m² un atelier 1000 m²
pour résumer l'avantage de la tulimètre
carré c'est qu'on va pouvoir réaliser
une activité qu'on n'avait pas dans le
livre de France qu'elle l'intégration
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait on va faire du
montage directement dans notre atelier
pour livrer les machines directement à
nos clients là où on faisait cette cette
activité à l'extérieur de
l'Île-de-France dans notre groupe et
donc le but était aussi de regrouper
toutes vos filiales
des innovations on a énormément
d'oignons d'innovation on parle de la
réalité virtuelle on parle de logiciel
qui permet d'accompagner nos clients sur
l'augmentation de production le suivi de
leur production aussi donc voilà ça on
parle beaucoup d'innovation et c'est
quelque chose qui qui nous
identifie auprès de nos clients puisque
on leur rapporte des innovations lors de
leurs besoins et on est capable de les
accompagner aussi bien sur l'outillage
que du coup ingénierie au niveau de
leurs produits on a on accompagne
actuellement typiquement Alstom sur
l'ascenseur à mobilité réduite du
nouveau TGV par exemple donc ça c'est
nous qui le font la co-ingénierie avec
eux et la fabrication dans nos ateliers
et alors en 15 ans vous avez triplé
votre chiffre d'affaires d'ici 2025 vous
visez les 600 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires votre entreprise on
dirait elle connaît pas la crise elle
n'a pas connu la crise c'est un peu le
cas c'est pour ça qu'on a énormément de
besoins en termes de recrutement
je précisais il y a à peu près il y a un
environ 50 postes ouverts sur
l'Île-de-France
qui passe de mécanicien
électromécanicien
d'acheteurs qualiticiens enfin voilà et
j'en passe
et on précise ce n'est que des contrats
c'est des oui alors pourquoi parce que
on est sur sur vraiment de l'expertise
une personne le temps de le former vont
mettre 3 à 6 mois pour être autonome sur
des prestations donc faire un CDD ou un
contrat mission pour nous il y a aucun
intérêt ce qu'on aura formé cette
personne pendant 3 et 6 mois je vois pas
l'intérêt de de faire ce genre de
contrat et donc ce sont des métiers où
vous avez du mal à recruter on a
beaucoup de mal et non vous l'expliquer
c'est ça intéresse peu c'est
la formation est longue c'est que voilà
les gens ont peut-être trouvé mais on
s'est vraiment des métiers de niche
typiquement parler de métrologie il y a
pas un diplôme de métrologie donc c'est
une formation interne on est obligé de
trouver des gens qui au moins
connaissent la lecture de plan mécanique
mais on peut pas trouver quelqu'un qui a
un diplôme métrologie ça n'existe pas
donc on parle de métrologie les gens la
plupart ne connaissent pas justement ce
métier là donc c'est un peu compliqué à
faire une annonce en précisant un poste
de métrologie et ça parle à très peu de
monde hormis les gens qui ont vu ça dans
des bacs technologiques puisque ils ont
quelques notions de métrologie dans leur
cursus mais c'est tout donc voilà c'est
un exemple donc si on a des potentiels
intéressés parmi nos téléspectateurs ils
peuvent candidater dès aujourd'hui
donc ça il y a pas de souci tous les
tous les les postes sont en ligne donc
voilà qui n'hésitent pas au contraire
ils seront reçus justement dans nos
nouveaux sites de 1600 mètres carrés
bien merci beaucoup Laurent du fourneau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
direction à présent l'usine d'un lopylo
situé à Limay à l'occasion des Journées
Européennes des Métiers d'Art le public
est invité à découvrir des animations
sur les métiers de l'artisanat mardi
dernier huit sculpteurs en herbe ont pu
s'essayer au modelage ils ont tenté de
reproduire des pieds ou des mains des
célèbres statues du château de
Versailles qui sont actuellement en
restauration le reportage de Patrick
Jacques de dispute et Julien Leroy
des petites sculptures sous le regard
des monumentales statues de l'Orangerie
cet engart réhabilité animée accueille
actuellement un chantier de restauration
pour quatre œuvres du château de
Versailles à l'occasion des Journées
Européennes des Métiers d'Art le public
était invité ce mardi 28 mars à
participer à un atelier de modelage avec
une artiste plasticienne objectif
reproduire des fragments de ces figures
représentants des dieux et déesses de la
mythologie grecque j'essaye de leur déjà
leur faire découvrir la matière leur
expliquer que la l'argile est utilisée
souvent aussi comme une esquisse comme
une ébauche dans un projet comme celui
qui est derrière moi beaucoup plus
volumineux c'est une des plus vieilles
méthodes de sculpture en fait on va
mettre les sourcils comme ça et après on
a un nez
au sein de ce chantier exposition le
réveil de la pierre les huit créateurs
en herbe ont pu modeler un pied ou un
visage l'occasion d'aiguiser son regard
et sa dextérité grâce à un matériau
malléable permettant les erreurs de
débutants
n'est pas artiste sache c'est
je pense à toutes les travail qui il
faut il faut faire là pour le pour
rénovation
de découvrir ce que sont ces métiers qui
ne sont pas connus qui sont des métiers
de l'ombre mais d'excellence de
l'artisanat qui font appel à des
compétences tout à fait remarquables le
dernier seront organisés durant ces
journées européennes des métiers d'art
découverte ce dimanche 2 avril des
savoir-faire d'un tailleur de pierre et
d'un conservateur
samedi prochain Fontenay fleuri organise
une après-midi olympique sur le plateau
Descartes son nom est tout trouvé
olimpidais pour en parler avec nous
Pascal Renaud la mère adjointe déléguée
à l'événementiel et à la vie associative
pour la commune de Fontenay
2 au niveau qui vient de nous rejoindre
en plateau bonsoir alors le programme
s'annonce chargé parce qu'elle Renaud
pour ce samedi après-midi il y en aura
pour tous les goûts qu'on soit aussi
bien sportif ou un peu plus un peu un
peu moins sportif plus porté sur le
théâtre je crois tout à fait il y en
aura pour tous les goûts en fait on va
parler aussi bien santé donc on aura des
professionnels de santé qui sont là
nutritionnistes podologue ostéopathe
kiné il y aura donc la possibilité de de
pouvoir discuter avec eux sur je suis
blessée je suis malade est-ce qu'il y a
un sport qui est adapté pour moi on
pourra tester sa forme physique puisque
le Comité olympique nous met à
disposition le village olympique donc il
y aura un stand de santé donc voilà donc
ça c'est la première étape c'est se dire
que finalement la seule limite en
général c'est nous on est notre propre
ennemi et que tout le monde peut faire
ne serait-ce qu'une activité une
activité physique marcher on peut tous
se faire voilà on a vu avec le covid
la santé c'est important aujourd'hui on
a le numérique qui rentre dans le dans
le travail on est de plus en plus
sédentaire et il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse bouger donc ce pôle santé il est
important et pourquoi pourquoi faire
venir des nutritionnistes des
kinésithérapeutes des ostéopathes
c'était aussi pour susciter des
dévocations peut-être chez les plus
jeunes ou alors pourquoi pas mais c'est
aussi pour se dire que le sport c'est
quel sport est adapté alors je suis
sportive mais finalement peut-être que
je fais pas à la bonne fréquence c'est
peut-être pas forcément le bon sport
c'est peut-être pas forcément le bon
dosage donc c'est aussi avoir ce retour
d'un spécialiste quand je suis sur mon
vélo j'ai peut-être pas forcément la
bonne position voilà donc c'est avoir ce
retour ou quand je suis blessée
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est-ce
que je ne peux pas faire donc c'était
pouvoir répondre à toutes les questions
des sportifs dénon sportifs des plus
jeunes et des moins jeunes donc ce pôle
santé il est vraiment c'est finalement
c'est l'entrée en matière ensuite on a
la partie culture qui est importante et
je voudrais que le sport
fasse vraiment ce lien avec la culture
mais pourquoi intégrer de la culture
dans cette partie ça fait partie des JO
la culture la culture et un axe des Jeux
Olympiques et finalement le sport va
nous emmener là où on l'attend pas et
voilà la culture donc il y aura un match
d'impro et finalement on va pouvoir
tester son aisance verbale on sera dans
le même dans une la même logique un
match de tennis les 16e les 8e etc et à
la fin de la journée on aura les jeunes
du foot de la section foot du collège
les 6e qui vont nous faire le
représentation puisque ils ont un projet
avec le théâtre donc ce lien se porte
théâtre un sport culture en tout cas
c'est pour nous c'est un héritage qui
doit perdurer après l'igo c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment important donc il y aura
de la culture il y aura bien sûr la
pratique d'activité sportive
que soit voilà du rugby de l'escrime du
basket mais on aura aussi les nouvelles
disciplines l'escalade le breakdance et
puis des disciplines paralympiques avec
le Cécifoot le hands fauteuil et le
tennis de table en fauteuil c'est
important d'intégrer ces disciplines par
olympiques oui tout à fait c'est
important de se dire que finalement le
sport voilà il est ouvert à tous on peut
dépasser son handicap en arrivant Wendy
qui nous le dira très bien puisque lui
il a perdu la vue il avait 10 ans et
finalement aujourd'hui il est hors de
question de lui dire que la première
chose qu'on remarque chez lui c'est
qu'il ne voit pas c'est un athlète qui
justement peut nous faire nous faire
nous dépasser et guimau aussi enfin
voilà c'est on peut on peut aller là où
finalement on ne sait pas qu'on peut
aller oui je le rappelle vous êtes guide
handisport pourquoi c'était important
pour vous de participer à cet après-midi
olympique
j'interviens souvent beaucoup au niveau
des associations et voilà moi j'aime
bien
c'est un peu mon cheval de bataille de
pouvoir montrer à tout un chacun comment
se dépasser comment aussi appréhender le
handicap parce que c'est une forme de
sensibilisation aussi en France on a
beaucoup de mal à appréhender le
handicap et avec en plus la venue des
jeux ça va nous permettre aussi de
surpasser un petit peu cette cette
notion voilà cette impression que peut
avoir les notamment les adultes parce
que les enfants en général ils
participent sans difficulté à des
sensibilisations handicales handisport
alors que les adultes ils sont un petit
peu un petit peu peur de se mettre dans
un fauteuil ou de se mettre en
déficience visuel ou autre de peur
d'être handicapé par la suite et donc
vous allez faire des démonstrations
voilà moi je vais mettre en situation
les personnes quel que soit ça peut être
aussi des personnes en situation de
handicap
déficience visuelle leur habitué avec
une avoir une
double un double handicap par exemple et
voir comment ils pourront se débrouiller
aussi tout en s'amusant parce que
l'objectif aussi c'est de le faire et de
prendre du plaisir ou de s'amuser et
alors donc on le disait beaucoup de
sport vous avez il y a aussi d'autres
sports un peu moins classiques comme le
breakdance l'escalade qui sont de
nouveau sport olympique c'était une
volonté ça aussi tout à fait de pouvoir
les proposer et de pouvoir les tester et
de se dire bah finalement c'est pour moi
j'y vais et voilà d'ouvrir les horizons
ça je pense que c'est important et il y
aura aussi du laser
cours en tir en cours et on tire voilà
d'accord
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup à vous
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation si
vous êtes intéressé par l'Olympie des
c'est samedi prochain de 14h30 à 18h30
sur le plateau des cartes de
Fontenay-le-Fleury allez c'est l'heure
maintenant vous parler de cinéma quels
sont les films à l'affiche de cette
semaine on fait le point tout de suite
[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous Céline Charles
comme tous les mercredis on fait le
point sur les sorties ciné de la semaine
et ce soir on commence par un super
héros qui va reprendre du service il
s'agit du super-héros Shazam de DC
Comics qui revient pour un second opus
la rage des dieux on retrouve badson cet
adolescent un peu bene capable de se
transformer en adulte super-héros en
prononçant le mot Shazam dans ce nouveau
film Billy à le complexe de l'imposteur
il ne se sent pas à la hauteur mais
malgré tout lui et sa fratrie surnommée
les désastres de Philadelphie vont
devoir prendre leur responsabilité
lorsque le monde sera menacé par trois
anciennes déesses un film plein d'humour
et d'action regardé
coup de changement ces dernières années
sortie ma doté de super pouvoir
S
sont à notre poursuite
des enfants se sont emparés du pouvoir
de tous les kids
ils l'ont arraché au tréfond de notre
père attendez je me dis qu'il faudrait
peut-être que je le note tout ça non
dans les pouvoirs mon enfant
vous vous laissez pouvoir aller les
chercher et vous nous proposez un autre
film Céline il est français et parle de
la justice restaurative mais aussi c'est
le terme ne vous disent pas grand chose
c'est normal c'est justement la magie du
film que d'arriver à nos plonger au cœur
de cette méthode judiciaire méconnue le
principe et pourtant simple des victimes
rencontres des détenus pour dialoguer le
tout encadré par des professionnels
médiateurs c'est une forme de théopie de
thérapie par la libération de la parole
dans je verrai toujours vos visages de
Jeanne Herry on suit alternativement le
parcours le parcours de victimes et
d'auteurs d'infractions qui se sont
engagés dans cette aventure regardez
ce que vous proposez à ces gens c'est
l'inverse de ce que tout le monde leur a
toujours proposé on ne parle pas à leur
place on ne suggérer rien on écoute on
accueille inconditionnellement
j'aimerais revoir mon frère j'ai pas
envie de le croiser par hasard enfin je
veux le voir pour être sûr de pas le
croiser par hasard j'étais agressé dans
le supermarché dans lequel je
travaillais à 5 ans je suis là pour vous
dire ce qui se passe pour les victimes
quand vous commettez ce genre de choses
j'ai 25 ans et j'ai braqué une supérette
j'ai passé toute ma vie dans le monde
des stupéfiants ça fait 25 ans que je
fais les allers-retours entre la prison
et l'extérieur
alors un film comme on a pu le voir qui
rassemble un casting 4 étoiles Adèle
l'exarco polos Leïla Bekti ou encore
Gilles Lellouche oui j'avoue que j'ai
très envie de regarder ce film pour le
coup je crois que Pascal légumes romain
aussi
on termine votre sélection Céline avec
le film d'animation de la semaine tout à
fait Mathilde c'est un film d'animation
ukrainien fabriqué à caisse durant
plusieurs années il a su se montrer plus
fort que la pandémie de covid est que la
guerre dans ce film humain et créature
fantastique de la forêt vivent
séparément et ne s'entendent pas
jusqu'au jour où Naya la nouvelle élu de
la forêt enchantée rencontre Lucas un
jeune humain égaré dans les montagnes
malgré les règles établies depuis des
millénaires ils vont se revoir et tomber
amoureux sans faire bien sûr attention
aux conséquences qui vont s'abattre sur
le royaume ce film c'est un petit peu le
une sorte de Roméo et Juliette
fantastique sous font d'appels à la paie
au respect de la nature un film
d'animation du coup un peu plus léger
qui fait du bien aussi merci beaucoup
Céline Charles on en avec de la danse et
plus particulièrement avec du ballet
samedi dernier cette tenue un atelier
chorégraphique à Saint-Cyr l'école
l'état animée par deux danseurs
professionnels de la compagnie d'Angelin
prêle local et c'était à l'initiative de
Saint-Cyr l'école danse et nous sommes
avec la directrice de cette école
Clarisse massalou bonsoir bonsoir et
nous sommes également avec l'un des
danseurs de Saint-Cyr l'école danse
Norman Reignier bonsoir bonsoir alors
tout d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce qu'est un atelier
chorégraphique bien sûr alors
initialement notre école a pour habitude
de subventionner et de permettre des
sorties pédagogiques et donc un accès à
la culture en vue de permettre aux
élèves et aux familles de nos adhérents
de nos élèves d'avoir un accès à
déballer et c'est dans ce cadre là que
nous faisons intervenir des danseurs de
compagnie
d'oeuvre qui sont en tournée ou qui
présente des créations ou des oeuvres de
compagnie en l'occurrence ici dans un
préjoccage et qui viennent faire des
ateliers et donc étudier l'oeuvre
chorégraphique que les élèves vont être
amenés à voir et plus particulièrement
certaines parties de cet œuvre alors
comment s'est déroulée cet atelier alors
on a proposé on a fait intervenir deux
danseurs pour deux catégories catégories
d'âge d'abord pour des enfants et
adolescents à partir de 8 ans et ensuite
pour des adultes donc
voilà en l'occurrence
d'autres élèves donc notamment Norman
voilà l'objectif étant d'avoir une
approche pédagogique adaptée à l'âge de
l'élève qui qui est présent donc vous
avez travaillé sur le Lac des cygnes en
compagnie donc de deux danseurs
professionnels de cette compagnie
qui a une renommée c'était un honneur
pour vous j'imagine oui c'était un
honneur et c'est une réelle réalisation
pour les élèves une réelle plus-value
de pouvoir accéder à la chorégraphie à
au travail chorégraphique à
l'interprétation d'un balai je dis
toujours aux élèves que la danse elle se
danse elle se pratique mais elle se
regarde elle se comprend et elle
s'interprète et c'était tout l'objectif
de cet atelier
de permettre une complémentarité dans le
projet pédagogique qui leur est proposé
alors comment c'est fait la relation
entre vous et la compagnie engelin trend
jocage alors c'est une compagnie que je
connais depuis longtemps j'ai pris
l'initiative d'appeler la compagnie qui
propose des ateliers aussi bien envers
des écoles quand vers des scolaires ou
envers d'autres structures en
l'occurrence notre école répondait
ces ateliers qu'il propose et c'est donc
dans ce cadre qu'on s'est on s'est
parfaitement mis d'accord et entendu sur
l'intervention qui qui a été faite donc
au total une soixantaine d'élèves donc
vous Norman Reignier comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu cet atelier
chorégraphique qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
que vous avez appris qu'est-ce qu'il
vous ont transmis ces danseurs alors
qu'est-ce qui se font transmis nous ont
transmis beaucoup déjà leur énergie
parce que ça leur demande beaucoup
d'énergie et ça on a vu que même pour
nous en apprentissage c'était assez
impressionnant
qu'est-ce qu'on a appris
c'est l'endurance qui était vraiment
assez intense parce que pour nous
d'apprendre une chorégraphie une
chorégraphie de cette manière et de
façon intensive c'était c'était assez
difficile mais on y a réussi voilà on a
appris un très beau passage de du Lac
des cygnes donc on était très content de
pouvoir le voir en réalisation après en
live
c'était vraiment une plus-value pour
vous d'être accompagné par des danseurs
professionnels
j'ai commencé en septembre
c'est quelque chose que vous faites
assez régulièrement Clarisse que faire
venir des compagnies un peu renommées
pour faire des que c'est possible on le
fait tout à fait on trouve qu'il y a une
vraie complémentarité aussi bien de voir
une oeuvre de la prendre
voilà et d'avoir un travail bien sûr
quotidien du danseur donc dès que ça
nous est possible on le fait tout à fait
et donc les plus petits en âge les huit
ans ils en ont pensé quoi de cet atelier
chorégraphique à peu près la même chose
je dirais que les adultes petit et
grands étaient réagi donc voilà chaque
partie deux parties différentes tu
distinguent du Lac des cygnes ont été
abordés une adaptée aux enfants qui ont
également eu le plaisir de de retrouver
de le découvrir sur scène avec les
danseurs de la compagnie au Théâtre
Royal de Versailles qui qui passe encore
pendant quelques jours
et ils ont voilà ils ont tous été tous
été ravis
et ravi on était ils étaient les enfants
étaient 37 de les canaliser ça va et ça
a été ça a été c'était c'était un vrai
challenge parce que normalement en cours
on prend allez on prend entre 10 et 20
élèves grand maximum normalement voilà
c'est plutôt une dizaine
et là en l'occurrence sur des ateliers
justement on augmente le nombre pour
permettre l'accès à cette rencontre au
maximum mais il y avait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants ils étaient
ils étaient 35 et très très assidu très
à l'écoute très attentif peut-être un
peu impressionné par les danses
également tout à fait vous le disiez
tout à l'heure ce sont des stages de
perfectionnement des ateliers
chorégraphiques qui s'inscrivent dans
votre dans un pédagogique c'est
important pour vous de pas seulement
faire de l'apprentissage mais de faire
découvrir la culture de la danse et du
balai oui oui tout à fait et puis les
différents styles de danse aussi notre
école propose du contempo jazz à accès
plus sur le jazz et du classique mais
l'objectif de ces sorties c'est
également de découvrir d'autres styles
d'autres chorégraphes d'autres manières
d'amener la danse de l'interpréter de la
découvrir et de la pratiquer donc il y a
une prochaine date à retenir enfin alors
on a rajouté une sortie cette année
puisque on avait énormément de demandes
et certains balais étaient complets donc
j'ai rajouté une date au dernier moment
et on va découvrir l'histoire de Manon à
l'Opéra Garnier avec la compagnie
nationale de Paris très belle opéra
c'est quelque chose que vous aimez vous
Norman Reignier de faire partie de cette
école de danse mais en plus d'aller
pouvoir aller voir des des opéras des
balais le spectacle de danse mais la
chance qu'on a d'avoir une professeur
comme Clarisse c'est justement de
toucher de près et d'avoir peut-être
aussi des explications sur certaines
choses qu'on ne comprendrait pas pour ma
part et de pouvoir jouer vraiment entrer
dans le détail de peaufiner et notamment
quand on a eu la chance de découvrir de
danseurs comme on l'a découvert c'était
parfait et bien merci beaucoup Clarisse
un plateau avec nous si vous êtes
intéressé vous retrouvez plus
d'informations sur le site internet de
Saint-Cyr l'école danse on passe un tout
autre sujet à présent après le concours
de Miss supranational France l'année
dernière où elle avait terminé première
dauphine l'artisienne l'aura auménie
décroche une nouvelle fois l'écharpe de
première dauphine dans l'Eure-et-Loir et
elle est avec nous ce soir le
Royaume-Uni bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde
merci de me recevoir alors pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez décidé de
participer à ce concours Miss
Eure-et-Loir parce que je suis en étude
pour devenir notaire et les études se
finissent cette année donc je me suis
dit que j'allais tenter mon rêve
d'enfant de participer à un concours qui
était rattaché à l'organisation Miss
France donc pour plus m'impliquer et je
suis partie donc dans l'Eure-et-Loir
parce que j'ai déménagé depuis voilà
vous êtes maintenant que vous habitez à
bu plus dans les Yvelines
je travaille toujours parce que ça je
sais enfin je resterai rattaché à mon
département d'origine mais j'ai dû
déménager dans l'Eure-et-Loir et alors
comment s'est passé ce concours pour
vous qu'elles ont été les étapes parce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer alors on
a déjà passé un casting donc moi j'avais
pas pu passer le casting donc j'ai
contacté le comité par mail j'ai pu voir
avec eux je leur ai donné certaines
informations après j'ai rencontré les
candidates pour le shooting officiel
donc ma candidature a été retenue à ce
moment là quand j'ai rencontré le comité
et après on avait des séances de
répétition des moments avec les filles
où on est parti déposer des affiches
j'ai essayé de faire un peu connaître le
concours pour avoir du monde le jour J
et puis à l'élection alors comment on se
prépare à un concours de beauté parce
qu'il y a des règles à suivre il y a pas
forcément de règles en plus on a un
comité qui est vraiment très très
arrangeant et très proche de nous donc
finalement ils sont très bienveillants
et après pour le concours de beauté en
lui-même on apprend à défiler on fait
des chorégraphies d'ailleurs ça m'a
donné envie de reprendre la danse à la
rentrée donc je note évidemment les
adresses et après on a aussi la prise de
parole on a un discours à préparer on a
des prises de parole qui se font sur les
plateaux télé à la radio qu'on doit un
peu préparer en amont si jamais on est
élu ou si on est dans les dauphines puis
voilà c'est pour le coup mais ça se
prépare pas forcément c'est plus ça
vient avec avec le comité d'organisation
qui nous Brive un peu et qui nous
explique comment ça va se passer alors
pendant le concours vous êtes jugé un
peu sur tous ces critères voilà on est
on est jugé effectivement sur le
physique parce que c'est quand même en
concours de beauté mais on est aussi
jugé sur le discours sur les ans qu'on a
sur scène parce que c'est pas forcément
évident d'être devant enfin autant
autant de personnes pour faire nos
chorégraphies et puis après on est jugé
aussi tout au long de l'aventure avec en
fait le comité regarde comment on se
comporte avec les autres jeunes femmes
si voilà si on est à l'aise si on est un
peu fait pour ça et si on est aussi
motivé impliqué si on est à présent te
répétitions si on s'investit et on voit
d'ailleurs quelques images de ce
concours alors vous avez fini première
dauphine de Miss Eure-et-Loir vous êtes
d'ailleurs venu avec votre écharpe c'est
une fierté pour vous vous êtes quand
même un peu déçu d'arriver en seconde
place non j'étais très contente parce
que en fait sur le moment déjà on avait
une très bonne promo donc je pense que
toutes les filles étaient méritantes et
c'est vrai que quand on est sur scène et
qu'ils appellent les noms on s'y voit
pas forcément donc sur le moment j'étais
très contente en fait de repartir avec
une écharpe parce que finalement en fait
l'aventure continue on a des événements
tout au long de l'année on va pouvoir en
fait je vais réaliser un peu mon rêve à
travers cette année-là donc Dauphine ou
Miss de toute façon ça m'allait très
très bien et donc vous êtes première
dauphine de Miss supranationale France
2022 oui et maintenant première dauphine
de Miss Ecer et Loire les deux se
conjuguent bien alors non parce que du
coup j'ai rendu mon titre en janvier
pour Miss supranational France et donc
là pour en tant que première dauphine de
Miss Eure-et-Loir vous allez avoir des
missions je suppose on a beaucoup
d'événements qui en fait le comité est
assez assez arrangeant là dessus parce
que tous les événements tombent en
week-end ou en soir deux semaines pour
éviter que ce soit sur les études ou le
travail et après on a pas mal de choses
qui se succèdent c'est assez rythmé donc
c'est pour ça que je préférais attendre
la fin des études pour vont me lancer là
dedans et comme maintenant les critères
ont été
élargies je pouvais en forme présenter
et donc c'est quoi la suite pour vous
est-ce que vous avez prévu d'autres
concours ou alors j'attends de voir si
on peut participer à l'élection
régionale on sait pas encore comment ça
va se passer ça sera le 17 septembre
pour l'élection régionale et puis sinon
je vais vivre mon aventure cette année
et voir par la suite ce qui ce qui
s'offrira à moi vous le disiez du coup
vous suivez des des études de droit pour
devenir notaire est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous allez mettre en avant qui
va vous aider dans votre parcours
professionnel alors je pense que les
deux s'alimentent parce que donc par
exemple quand j'ai fait mon élection
j'ai dû faire un discours devant
énormément de personnes et ce matin
j'étais en examen pour un oral et je me
suis dit que finalement si j'arrivais à
parler devant autant de personnes pour
mon discours il y avait pas de problème
pour l'oral et que j'avais pas besoin de
stresser donc je pense que les deux en
fait vont bien se conjuguer j'apprends
sur les deux terrains et en effet c'est
quelque chose à mettre en avant parce
que je suis très fière de ma profession
et très fière des études que j'ai
entrepris et bien merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel sera dégagé sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines avec des
températures assez douces 11 degrés à
Rambouillet 12 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles et 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
temps se dégrade un peu avec des averses
à prévoir côté température le
thermomètre montera à 16 degrés en
moyenne sur le département et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]